en Libia se hizo evidente la
fragmentación del mundo árabe en trípoli
se realizó una reunión preparatoria para
la Cumbre de ministros de exteriores del
bloque que se celebra en El Cairo Egipto
sin embargo la asistencia fue más que
reducida de los 22 miembros solo cinco
enviaron a sus delegados solo Argelia y
túnez mandaron a sus ministros de
exteriores mientras que Sudán las
comoras y el gobierno palestino enviaron
a representantes Egipto emiratos árabes
Unidos y arabias Saudita figuraban por
su parte entre Los ausentes que no
reconocen al gobierno en funciones en
trípoli el jefe de la liga También
estuvo ausente Lidia lamentó el boicot
me preocupa la posición de algunos
países así como los actos deplorables
que se repiten desde que Libia ejerció
su derecho a presidir el consejo de la
liga creemos que está lamentable
ausencia no contribuye a la estabilidad
de mi país en febrero de 2022 un año
después de la formación de un gobierno
de unidad nacional dirigido por abdel
hamid veiba el parlamento de Brook en el
este del país decidió nombrar a fathi
bachaga como Primer Ministro
Estableciendo así Un gobierno paralelo
la colisión entre los dos hombres es
producto del fracaso del proceso
electoral que las Naciones Unidas Habían
intentado promover la imposibilidad de
organizar elecciones debito advaiva que
también perdió apoyos al presentarse
como candidato a la presidencia a
finales de 2021 Pese a que su cargo le
prohibía hacerlo su rival bachata ha
hecho causa común con jalifa haftar el
hombre fuerte del este y desde entonces
el gobierno de trípoli patrocinado por
la ONU y el de tov Brook apoyado por el
bando de jalifa haftar se disputa en el
poder diez años después de la caída del
régimen de gadafi asesinado en 2011 este
enfrentamiento entre dos autoridades
profundiza la partición del país